drone technology has come a long way
over the last decade the unmanned
aircraft are now being used for
everything from making movies to
delivering medical supplies in remote
areas but the technology has a dark side
in the wrong hands drones could be used
to spy on us and have they often
threaten all right our very
infrastructure and even target civilians
in a Washington Post op-ed this month
homeland security secretary Kirsten
nielsen warned of the dangers writing in
part without congressional action the US
government will remain unable to
identify track and mitigate weaponized
or dangerous drones in our skies here to
discuss these concerns is wired
magazine's editor-in-chief Nicholas
Thompson Nick good morning we're not
talking about military gray drones here
we're talking about commercially
available drones how big a threat are
they actually they are actually a pretty
substantial threat we have seen
recreational drones be news to drop
contains on American soldiers in Mosul
we've seen them being used by drug
dealers we have seen them being used by
gangs on the other hand they're also
amazing and so we need drones to come
forward we just need to make sure they
don't blow us up so that's a hard
problem for government and what sort of
ways are they using this technology
well the Isis in some of these other
nefarious entities so the drones have
not been used to harm American civilians
yet but hypothetically you could as was
done in Iraq you could attach grenades
in a drone and drop them you could use
perhaps even for chemical weapons you
can drop a chemical weapons on a
population in the worst case scenario
you could fly a drone over a large
gathering of people and release
something toxic that would be horrible
so we need to know how to prevent that
well at the same time letting all these
good things happen at the moment anybody
can buy a drone so how does the
government begin to address this well
what needs to happen is the regulations
need to be made very clear right so
right now there are regulations you
can't fly a drone over 400 feet you have
to keep within line of sight the
regulations on the limits and weight but
there are a lot of things the government
can't do right a government can't Jam a
drone right now it can't Jam the
technology and confuse it and take it
down because of surveillance and
wiretapping laws it can't shoot a drone
out of the sky because of regulations
about shooting down aircrafts it might
fall on people
so you need to allow the government to
track the drones regulate the drones
monitor the drones and take down the
drones but do that in a way that again
doesn't destroy the industry well
Homeland Security has asked for just
that is anyone in Congress listening
Congress is listening the White House is
paying attention the problem is with as
with any new technology there's a real
back-and-forth because you don't want to
make the regulations too severe it's not
exactly clear how you do it my personal
favorite idea for how to stop drones is
to Train Eagles they're doing that in
and it's really bad for the talons but
it is possible no really what you need
to do is the best way to do it is
radiofrequency jamming yeah be able to
track the drones and also you need to be
able to regulate the drones so that
they're not allowed to fly within
certain areas and you can be able to
update the software so that that can be
constantly changed that when the
Superbowl happens it is impossible to
fly a drone near the stadium how is law
enforcement dealing with this right now
Nick law enforcement is perplexed they
want more tools and they have they have
some FAA regulations that are really
hard to enforce it's hard for a
policeman driving a car to say oh wait
your drones more than four hundred feet
high
you're in trouble the authorities they
have any special gadgets other than the
Eagles flying around and handle this
they do but they can't use them I mean
that is actually one of the worst things
about drone regulation are now is that
we know how to jam them we actually know
how to fire nets and catch a drone
rather than 100 feet of where the net
goes right and that doesn't like knock
the drone down on the crowd but they're
not allowed to use them yet Wow not a
problem
it's a problem but it is a solvable
problem and ideally the good people
united states government can solve it I
like that attitude yeah let's go get it